you've mentioned
south america latin america multiple
times venezuela you must have some
strong feelings on what's going on in el
salvador
with naive buchelli the president of el
salvador is that someone
you follow or you're in touch with or
anything like that the situation in el
salvador is uh
is
instructive
because el salvador
doesn't have their own currency
they had a war a civil war and following
the civil war their currency collapsed
and so they dollarized
so the medium of exchange in el salvador
has been the dollar
and so
their problem is and and
and was
that uh the banking system the us
banking or the traditional 20th century
banking system is too expensive and
cumbersome to serve the people of el
salvador
over a hundred years they managed to put
two and a half million people into a
banking relationship
over three weeks they rolled out um a
crypto wallet the chivo wallet
and they put three million people into
that system so they accomplished more in
three weeks with digital assets than
they accomplished in 300 years
with physical assets
right i mean i don't it's kind of ironic
we're sitting in a bank vault right now
a converted bank vault and and you're
sitting in a converted bank building but
there's probably no better point to make
which is
think about how
incredibly inefficient and ineffective
it is
to store money in vaults across a
hundred thousand buildings with tens of
millions of people trying to shuffle
people
pieces of paper around
defended by people with guns and
militaries and navies and air forces
and governments and policemen and court
systems and armies of accountants and
lawyers we uh we might have froze
david do we know what's going on
uh working on it
looks like it's back
see if it's back for you
what are the people saying in the
comments
i'm just trying to get one i see rebecca
okay go forward you were saying so
so the the 20th century way of banking
and finance is obscenely expensive and
ineffective and at the end of the day
it leaves two three billion people in
the world unbanked
with and is hopeless
it is hopeless it is the same problem we
had during the first wave of internet
computing where we used wired lines
cable lines in order to deliver the
signal
and that was hopeless for africa and so
the mobile wave was
we put the signal on a tower and now i
can put up one tower and give internet
access to millions and millions of
people
for one one thousandth of the cost of
doing it with the copper
line
technique
so if you think about digital banking
the future of the world is 8 billion
people with mobile phones
i download an application in 60 seconds
and on that mobile phone i carry a
digital currency like the dollar
maybe the euro
maybe a local maybe the yen or the one
maybe if there's an effective nation
state
if there's not an effective nation state
i just clearly swap out to the dollar
immediately everybody would want to do
that and then i also carry a digital
property bitcoin
i want to hold it for 100 years it's a
you know instead of holding a building
which you can you can tax or seize or
rain on
or instead of like holding a bar of gold
which you can take from me i'm just
going to hold my digital bar of gold on
my phone
and then maybe i have some other assets
maybe i have digital art maybe i have
digital securities you know maybe
copies of
ownership of something else that i might
like sitting in a wallet
but certainly
this i can give to everybody on earth
and i can move the money at the speed of
light
and what do i trust i'm trusting a piece
of software
which is
which is a lot cheaper and a lot more
reliable than trusting a building a bank
a board of directors a ma
when you actually have your money in
this bank vault i mean look at it
imagine money in the
[Music]
think about that when you had your money
there you were trusting the guy that ran
the bank the manager the bank the mayor
the head of the police force of the bank
the head of security of the bank the
dude that came to actually fix the lock
everyone that touched the thing
the governor of the state then you're
trusting the head of the country the
central bank that managed the country
the military system who do you trust
with bitcoin
nobody
that's the point
nobody bitcoin's a bank in cyberspace
run by software incorruptable software
and this is
this is the beauty right really great
engineering it takes an a corruptable
element
and puts corruptable or imperfect
elements together in a system such that
they cancel out their imperfections to
create perfection
where did this happen happens in a
thermostat
in a thermostat i you know i have um i
have a strata or
a metal and the metal contracts
when it gets cold and expands when it
gets hot
okay now i tell you build something
which doesn't contract and expand when
it gets cold and it gets hot you're an
engineer how do you do it
you take the you take the piece of metal
that's going to contract and you put it
in opposition to another piece of metal
that contracts the other way but if
they're both the same and they both
contract with the same force
and you pin them they cancel each other
out
and then you actually get a zero
tolerance perfect machine
that's how john harrison created a
perfected clock he basically used that
insight that imperfect elements can
create a perfect mechanism and a clock
that clock was used to calculate
longitude on the ocean
that's how we actually navigated for 300
years it it's all based upon a bunch of
imperfect elements that create a perfect
mechanism
bitcoin is the same thing
i've got a piece of software that runs
on a machine is it perfect no why
because you can corrupt it
how do i fix it i give another piece of
software
to him
now the two of each of your machines
check each other
well what if you're both corrupted
well i throw another 10 000 of those
pieces of software into the ether well
who do i give them to people i don't
know
how do i corrupt them how do i even find
them
okay what if i promised a murder
everybody in the u.s that doesn't change
their bitcoin nodes doesn't help
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]